this video will explain the story of
atomic heart we'll be talking about the
main story as well as the two endings
and by the end you should have a better
understanding as to what went on here as
always spoiler warning ahead if you
haven't played atomic heart please come
back after you have done so as we're
talking about some endgame information
in just a minute if you enjoyed the
video then feel free to check out the
other videos we have here on the channel
we have some informative ones like this
on a myriad of other games as well as a
lot of story critiques where we look at
the game's story and analyze its quality
if any of that sounds interesting to you
then check out some of my other videos
after this one with that out of the way
though thanks for clicking on the video
and let's get started so atomic heart
starts us in a boat we play as comrade
major or P3 as he's alternately called
and is on his way to his next assignment
P3 is an agent who served in World War
II and is currently working for a doctor
sechinoff the year is 1955 but it
doesn't look like it and that's because
atomic heart takes place in an alternate
version of our own world the only
difference is that prior to World War II
Russia discovered a substance called
polymer this was initially founded by Dr
sechinoff himself after a couple of
years Russia assembled a team of
scientists to learn more about this
mysterious substance you'll recognize
most of their names as some of them have
places named after them in game like
Pavlov however the only important one is
zacharoth the world then continues as
normal for a few years until we get to
1942 which is around the time of World
War II Germany ends up losing the war
like they do in real life but Germany
decided to go out with a bang and
release a deadly virus called the brown
plague it was so powerful that no meds
at the time could cure it and it would
force the world to come up with its own
vaccine after this in the mid-40s Russia
would also construct a base called
facility 3826 a place that was the apex
of the Soviet Union's technological and
scientific achievement this is also
where Collective 1.0 was born a neural
network that could bring mankind
together this neural network was created
to work with the robots that were also
being developed at the time which are
the ones we see throughout the game it's
very clear that thanks to polymer and Dr
sechenov's work Russia and the Soviet
Union were able to thrive as it's only
1955 yet they have fully functional
talking robots flying cities and are on
the cusp of breaking even more ground
within the Realms of science we know
this because one of the newspaper stands
talks about Soviet citizens seeing an
average life increase of over 100 more
years robots may be indistinguishable
from humans within about five years and
that Mikhail Kalashnikov the creator of
the AK-47 might be revisiting Carl
gauss's work on magnetism to hopefully
improve modern Weaponry on his way to
sachinoff's office we can explore and
look around this city in the clouds one
thing you'll see is atomic heart not
exactly being subtle with its
Inspirations as the iconic0451 code is
uttered in the first three minutes which
is probably the fastest I've ever heard
that code spoken in a game before while
walking the streets we also get
introduced to this device called thought
according to the vendor thought is
supposed to be paired with the newly
announced Collective 2.0 that's why
everyone here is celebrating and why
such enough can't meet with us right now
as he's currently busy making some last
minute preparations the first thing on
the docket is to meet with some robots
and get ourselves more in tune with our
glove P3 has a talking glove called
Charles but as we know from the ending
this is not Charles but Chariton world
renowned scientist and all-around genius
he was killed by sechinoff who then put
him in some polymer that dissolved his
body but suchinov kept his Consciousness
and put it in the glove P3 uses the
intention was for zakarov to help P3
complete the mission section off had
given to him but over the course of the
game we could see him come to his senses
which is why both zakarov and P3
confront sechinoff at the end I wanted
to bring this up now rather than wait
until the end since knowing that will
now provide more context for any scene
he's in later at the moment though P3
doesn't know any of this as he's here to
just do a simple job also from now on
any time I mentioned Charles or the
glove I'll be using his real name
zacharov so just keep that in mind the
reason P3 doesn't question anything
sachinoff does is because back during
World War II he saved his life which is
why he always does what he says he
believes that the boss has his best
interest at heart and knows that his
role in life is to not question things
but rather get things done as P3
approaches sechinoff's office we see
that a parade is going on which is
celebrating the launch of collective 2.0
according to the man himself it's a
better and faster neural network that
will will connect humans and robots
together unskilled labor will no longer
be necessary and humans can Master
academic subjects learn new languages
and so much more all this is thanks to
Collective 2.0 being created alongside
the thought device a device that
connects to the person's brain using a
tiny amount of neuropolymer this device
isn't being released today but rather in
a few days which helps out P3 as his
mission is directly related to this he
will then meet with the ballerina twins
who give him a key the ballerina twins
are sort of like sachinoff's left and
right hands in fact they literally are
as their names are left and right just
goes to show that even the smartest man
alive struggles with naming things as
for p3's Mission objective he's tasked
with going to facility 3826 the same one
we talked about earlier regarding
Russia's technological achievement
apparently something went wrong and The
Man Behind it is someone named petroth
once P3 arrives at facility 3826 he
discovers that the robots are hostile
and are attacking anything that's human
according to sachinoff Petrov hacked
into Collective and made the robots
attack the human employee stationed here
he wants P3 to bring him to his office
with his access codes intact so that he
could stop this mess as for how he
gained access to Collective this easily
while Petrov was the lead engineer on
Collective so he knew how it worked a
few months ago his betrayal was
discovered so they sent some special
forces to arrest him instead of
imprisoning or killing him though
sachinoff had put him on community
service because having their lead
engineer gone just months before release
would be a major blow to its development
it's unclear what they would have done
to him after the release but it didn't
matter as he was still able to enact his
plan given the state of the facility
while P3 travels throughout the facility
trying to piece together what happened
he ends up meeting with Granny Xena an
old lady who seems to be a secret
operative as she knows her way around a
weapon her inclusion seems rather out of
place but she'll have some relevance
later P3 will also meet with a doctor
Larissa when he's knocked out
unconscious Dr Larissa is working and is
in a relationship with Petrov the same
one who's causing all the robots to go
wild at the facility Dr Larissa figured
P3 was just a normal person who got
caught up in this mess but once he uses
the polymer device on the table she
realizes something is up as only some
people have have that capability that's
one she'll get in contact with Petrov
and alert him of p3's arrival which is
around the time the two meet Petrov then
uses a voice command to summon some Bots
allowing him time to escape as we search
for him though we see that he died due
to some loaderbot decapitating him this
is obviously not true as we'll see him
later but at the time it was assumed
that Petrov had died P3 will then get on
the comms until sechronoff would happen
despite What P3 believes section off
does not seem to be upset and instead
tells him to go to a place called The
vdnh said stockhausen can tell him what
to do next stockhausen is a German
scientist and seems to be the one who
debriefs P3 on what his mission
objectives are while escaping the
facility we can get a brief Glimpse as
to what went on here as these things
called Sprouts are mutating and
affecting the workers we also get to see
what I can only assume is the birthplace
of these Sprouts as it's the largest
plant in this whole facility only to
blow this thing up in order to get a
specific canister that allows us to
leave but along the way we'll learn more
about this section of the facility and
learned that it was created to test
various things from temperatures to
animal life with the intention of course
of colonizing the solar system it's hard
enough to get someone on the planet but
colonizing and being self-sufficient is
a totally different story which is why
the lab was using polymer to see if they
could come up with a solution once we
leave the facility we get to talk to
Charles and stockhausen as for Charles
he tells P3 the story of zakarov and how
he died this conversation is initiated
by P3 himself which means that zakarov
dying is a commonly known event amongst
the Soviet Union and its people Charles
says that his death is shrouded in
mystery and all that's known is that he
slipped into a bath of hazardous
neuropolymer while that does sound
pretty cut and dry Charles explains that
the labs are monitored 24 7 yet no one
saw it happen Dr sachinoff was the only
one that knew of this event P3 continues
to play the naive Soldier Boy and says
that you know things happen people slip
and cameras break nothing weird about
that he further states that maybe the
neuropolymer was just a dangerous strain
Charles does bring up a good point
though and says that Dr zakarov would
have known the dangers of the polymer
sample since he created that specific
one this is rather interesting since
zakarov is Charles so he's basically
spilling the details on his own death
without outright saying what happened P3
is as dense as a doorknob and the info
won't get through to him so whatever his
plan was regarding this conversation
likely didn't work after leaving the
underground bunker and getting topside
P3 runs into granny Xena again who has
something interesting to show him this
video is footage of a meeting between
sechronoff and Apollo Bureau the group
is worried about the malfunction caused
by Petrov because they believe their
so-called atomic heart project will be
in Jeopardy because of it comrade
Molotov the one who speaks on behalf of
the group plans to come by later today
and investigate this malfunction if
Molotov sees what really happened such
anov's reputation and the launch of
collective 2.0 will both be affected so
we have to fix this mess before he
arrives right before leaving no granny
Xena asks if P3 found any gold rings
back in the facility this is the same
question sachinoff asked us earlier
which begs the question of what these
rings are thankfully we have a lot of
time to speculate and talk as zacharoth
and P3 discuss these exact topics from
our talks with zakarov it seems like
comrade Molotov wants to take Collective
for himself P3 is confused by this as
according to all the reports on
Collective 2.0 everyone's supposed to be
equal within the network but Zach graph
explains that there are alpha beta and
gamma connectors that can be used within
Collective the alpha connector is the
main connector its purpose is to apply
discretionary Authority within
Collective it's sort of like being the
owner of a server you want people to be
equal and have a good time but someone's
got to make sure things go smoothly such
enough seems to have the alpha connector
with him which would make sense since
he's the founder of it the beta
connectors though allow someone to gain
access to Collective without being a
part of it Collective 2.0 was designed
to give humans the ability to control
robots these beta connectors would allow
these robots to not be controlled since
they would technically not be a part of
the network to relate this back to the
previous example it's sort of like a
lurking in a Discord server but no one
knows you joined you can see all the
chats and channels but no one can tell
that you're even there there are only
two beta connectors that exist and what
a coincidence that section off has two
twin robots these are his pride and joy
but since they're considered robots
they'd be a part of the collective but
section off doesn't want them to be
controlled by someone else from a normal
business angle this makes sense why
would someone be able to control the
CEO's own personal robots it's
understandable why those might be off
the list but you also have to remember
that these robots have combat functions
in them and the twins are quite deadly
they're basically his own personal
assassins that can never be controlled
due to the beta connectors furthermore
section off could also just destroy the
alpha connector once Collective is
launched preventing anyone from changing
the chain of command so basically
section off would use the alpha
connector to establish proper authority
over Collective then use the beta
connectors on his twin robots so that
not only can no one control them over
the network but also so that no one can
even see them on the network to begin
with such an awful then destroyed the
alpha connector which is the only way to
change the rules he's established but
since it would be gone the rules are
permanent thus giving him the upper hand
forever there is a lot more to this plan
though that we'll have to talk about in
a moment but things are now starting to
change as P3 feels more conflicted
regarding his feelings towards sechinoff
he won't have much time to think about
it though as comrade Molotov arrives
with his Soviet soldiers Molotov seems
to have such an off corner but offers to
meet in private to discuss what to do
shortly after P3 starts to hallucinate
before collapsing we then get thrown
into this weird dream sequence this
happens a couple times throughout the
game it is something we'll also have to
talk about later when P3 awakes everyone
is dead according to sachinoff robots
attacked and everyone died with him
Sachin often tells the twins to handle
the situation which involves taking
molotov's body and putting it in a bath
of this polymer goo but due to the
polymer being a dangerous but
communicative substance such enough is
able to dispose of the body and keep his
Consciousness this is exactly what
happened to zakarov his body was
consumed by the red polymer but while it
killed him it also saved his memories in
Consciousness allowing him to be
uploaded into something else later like
a glove as for why the thing looks human
well it's because sachinav wanted to
move independently as a human would
since the think can literally dissolve a
body in an instant things are now
starting to point towards cetronov not
exactly being as nice as he seems to be
and this will continue once we meet with
Petrov see Petrov didn't die in the
early parts of the game he tricked P3
into thinking that was the case so that
he could escape and send information
about the incident via broadcast to the
West this goes against our entire plan
as we were sent here to stop any anyone
even within the Soviet Union from
discovering what happened but if the U.S
finds out about Collective then we're
without a doubt screwed the question
though is why what exactly is the
problem here minus the obvious deaths of
course well let's look at the robots all
of them have specific duties but they
all for some odd reason have combat
modules installed in them they know how
to attack and were designed with
attacking in mind and that's the cause
for concern yes the Petrov made the
robots kill humans but if they were just
civilian robots made to pick up boxes or
transport Vehicles why do they have
combat modes in the first place Petrov
wanted the public to find out about the
massacres that Collective 2.0 and such
enough could be stopped this would also
inadvertently help the us since at the
moment the U.S government has drafted a
various sanctions on the robots CEOs of
big companies are trying to replace
their workers with these robots but
those workers of the work in class are
pissed that they're out of a job if it's
learned though that the robots can kill
people thanks to a simple malfunction
then they'd be immediately thrown out of
the country this would benefit the
working class but also the country as
well since the reason they're even being
given these other the robots is due to
the soviet's real goal the atomic heart
project earlier when we saw that meeting
between sechinoff and the politburo
molotov mentioned the atomic heart
project this is a plan made by the
Soviet Union to basically take over the
United States the plan was to give the
us as many robots as possible then when
they're ready the Soviets would activate
combat mode and basically cause what
happened here at the facility to happen
to the US instead but that's where these
sanctions come in because thanks to them
there's a limit on how Many Robots the
U.S can import at one time so the
process is taking longer than it should
Petrov and Dr Larissa want to stop this
all from happening which is why they
have been working together to broadcast
this information to the US before it's
too late given that their Soviet
citizens though it's weird that the two
are trying to stop this Petrov was the
lead engineer for Collective and Dr
Larissa studied under zakarov before he
became a talking glove so the two of
them have a deep appreciation for
Section off the Soviet Union and
Collective so they would have no reason
to betray Russia and they had no plans
to until they discovered something else
upon reaching Petrov and Dr Larissa we
see that P3 gets knocked out before
being strapped to a gurney p3s Petra why
he killed all these people and what it
was all for Dr Larissa is confused
because she claims that it was just a
local malfunction and nothing more seems
like Petrov never told her the full
story after realizing the horrors that
came from all this she leaves him and
never returns Petrov is in a state of
mania by the time we catch up to him at
the theater and he kills himself before
we can arrest him before dying though he
tossed his P3 a box that houses two gold
rings the beta connectors after telling
such an off what happened he sends in a
bot to take petrov's head such enough
plans to scan his brain and extract what
he needs using his head but to do that
P3 needs to bring the head to the Pavlov
complex on the way such an off
stockhausen and Granny Xena call and ask
about the gold rings again but P3 says
that he didn't find them he's unsure who
to trust at this point so he doesn't
want to reveal his hand too soon once P3
makes it to the labs he gives
stockhausen the head of Petrov and
extracts the access codes sadly the two
won't have enough time to do that as Dr
Larissa comes by and throws a grenade at
them the explosion knocks them both out
and allows the polymer to escape which
latches onto stockhausen dissolving his
body just like Molotov Dr Larissa then
calls P3 in a apologizes but she needed
to stop stockhauser before it was too
late she offers to make it up to him by
explaining what's really going on on the
way zakarov and P3 get into an argument
over the Rings claiming that if they
fail or give these rings away the world
would be screwed he claims that it's
better not to think about who'd be
better off with the Rings because they
could just destroy to prevent this all
from spiraling out of control P3 that
eventually decides to throw them in the
ocean which was the right call as for
more good news he'll also run into some
robots later but sachinoff managed to
get the access codes from petrov's head
so the combat mode is disabled sister
off congratulates P3 on some good work
and says that he should report back to
his office in chalamet for a checkup and
then take a vacation as he's earned it
before that though he wants to meet with
Dr Larissa as she claims to have the
answer as to what's going on referencing
our early discussion about subtlety
atomic heart once again pays homage to
his biggest inspiration Bioshock but
having P3 take an elevator that goes
past an underwater city if it wasn't
already obvious by that alone not only
is the music almost identical to
Bioshock 1's intro P3 calls the place a
Rapture and the elevators inside of a
lighthouse as I said very subtle once we
make it to the bottom we learn the real
story behind Collective down here in the
Academy of consequences is a lab fill
with test subjects all of these
individuals were test dummies for
Collective as such enough wants to be
able to control anyone who's a part of
the network and given that it's supposed
to be an international release he wants
to control the world according to Dr
Larissa all these individuals are in a
virtual world they call limbo their
minds are in their own dream worlds
while their bodies are used to do
whatever the host wants them to do
remember that weird dream realm a few
minutes ago that's limbo P3 has already
been affected by this limbo thanks to
such enough screwing with his head after
he was injured from the war do you also
remember that strange coincidence of P3
collapsing and then waking up to
everyone dead well while his mind was in
limbo p3's body was attacking Molotov
and his group it wasn't robots that
attacked them section off attacked them
using p3's body this manipulation is why
Petrov and Dr Larissa betrayed Russia
this isn't just the Soviet issue it's a
human rights issue attacking the US with
robots was one thing but taking over
people's minds by removing in their Free
Will is a totally different and much
bigger problem after this is when it's
revealed that Charles the AI glove was
actually zakarov the whole time P3
questions by section off even kept
zakarov around seems like a loose end if
you ask me while Larissa says that such
an awful would rather tweak things to
suit his needs rather than get rid of it
entirely which brings us to P3 his past
life and the twins Larissa shows p3some
recordings of the tests that were done
on him after helping P3 with his wounds
from World War II he implanted a device
called the neuropolymer brain function
extension the intention was to remove
all the destructive impulses that were
triggered by his PTSD but this wasn't a
coping mechanism that allows him to deal
with the pain as it comes but rather
remove it entirely by forgetting it
existed in the first place P3 was torn
apart over the death of his wife during
the World War but this removed all
memory of her he had no idea who his
wife was or that he was even married in
the first place furthermore it's learned
that when his wife died such enough
couldn't save her Consciousness as he
did with zakarov but he still decided to
use an imprint of her professional
skills as both a martial artist and a
ballet Arena and implant them into two
robots the twins now it's never
explicitly stated to my knowledge anyway
why section off would do this it can't
be because he cares about P3 and wants
him to get over the death of his wife by
having her imprints be a part of the
robots because P3 didn't even know he
was married the only thing I can come up
with is that the dude is just a creep
given the physique of the Twins and the
poses they strike during their dance
routines you get the sense that this is
for a lack of a better word something
that turns him on I don't really see any
other explanation for it regardless the
two then take the elevator and Ascend up
to the top but as they go up P3 goes
into limbo again which means section off
is forcing him to kill erisa once he
comes too he awakes on a floating
platform next to grainy Xena this is
where her relevance comes back into play
as she is his wife's mother or in other
words granny Xena is his mother-in-law
we're now given two choices each one
taking us to one of the endings of the
game if we choose to fight sechinoff we
then march to his office defeat The
Twins and confront him but it's all that
we were being deceived again it wasn't
Sentinel who was putting P3 in limbo
causing him to kill Molotov and Larissa
it was zacharov judging by zakarov's
decision to shock P3 right after this we
can assume that he's telling the truth
we didn't see zakarov used the polymer
to transform and then kill sentinov and
take what I assume is the alpha
connector and destroy it he then sends
P3 into limbo again allowing him to be
happy in the dream world while zakarov
uses his body for whatever he needs so
there's a lot to one wrap here and it's
not exactly straightforward since the
game was lying the whole time and I was
admittedly also lying to you so that we
could get to the plot twist so to
explain in the most basic way possible
Ascension off seems to be the good guy
and zakarov is the bad guy it also seems
like the atomic heart project was
sentient off's idea and controlling
people and removing their Free Will with
zakarovs before entering his facility we
can read a book called atomic heart it's
basically a Manifesto detailing the
stages of the project and what the end
goal of the project is it's all in
Russian but translating it shows us the
steps most of it is irrelevant to the
main discussion but it's notable that
there is no mention of controlling
people and Collective 2.0 is only
mentioned once atomic heart is a plan by
the Soviet Union to take control of the
United States using combat robots the US
will buy these robots and place them at
points of interest like military bases
and power plants eventually though
activate combat mode in the US will be
destroyed Collective 2.0 will help Fast
Track the process as it will allow all
the robots to be activated at one time
without using radio communication thus
meaning that that reverting the command
is almost impossible according to the
meeting with senchenov and the pal
libero the dialogue implies that all of
them knew of the project and its goals
the reason why Molotov is concerned
during the meeting is that he's unaware
the malfunction was this problematic if
he sees that a simple malfunction could
wipe out a whole facility cension off is
screwed P3 being put in limbo to kill
Molotov with zakarov's plan he likely
wanted to kill the Russian government so
that no one could oppose him this worked
out for Ascension off as now Molotov
would have no idea about the malfunction
but now he's in deeper water than before
if the polar Bureau or the Russian
government finds out that not only are
the robots malfunctioning on a scale
this large but this malfunction killed a
member of the committee sentinov could
be arrested or given that it's Russia
just shot in the street that's why he
dissolves his body said he could get rid
of the evidence zakarov on the other
hand seems to have no connection to any
of this as his plan seems to be to
control the world notice how throughout
the game all the information on senshin
off Petrov Collective and the connectors
all comes from zakaroth he's trying to
convince P3 that sentinoff is the bad
guy said he can enact his own plan now
that doesn't mean zakarov lied about
everything I'm sure the stuff about the
connectors was true but the other
details like the mind control and the
thought devices are lies zakarov is also
likely trying to convince P3 to throw
away the beta connectors so that
sentinoff doesn't have the upper hand
allowing his own takeover to be easier
to further confirm that the mind control
is zakarovs doing when he transforms he
pets this strange animal whose model
looks similar to the one we have in the
dream Realms personally I'm still
confused as to what he's doing at the
end here but from what I can tell he's
destroying the alpha connector that's a
part of collective a lot of the previous
information though seems to be confirmed
in the other ending as P3 comes to his
senses and quits he leaves the building
and removes Acura from his body he also
starts to question everything he's been
told he says that if he was able to be
put in the limbo thanks descension off
why isn't he in limbo right now
furthermore he says that the brain
extension that's in his head was
zakarov's invention so he's been
enslaving people long before the thought
devices were even made he also says that
if sentronov wanted to actually enslave
people then he would have just used
those implants rather than the thought
devices if the current device already
works as intended why go through the
extra trouble of making another one do
the same thing the ending slides then
say that they have security footage
showing P3 leaving the facility and then
was never seen it again they say nothing
about Collective the manipulation or
anything that we learned about in the
past few minutes which means that
Collective was never about mind control
and sentinov has no plans to take over
the world by game logic this would be
the good ending and if we're going to
reference Bioshock again it's kind of
like Andrew Ryan's a man chooses a slave
obeys quote P3 has been ordered around
all game and just complies but for once
he's taking things into his own hands
and doing what he wants to do it's quite
the crazy twist that brings us to the
end of atomic heart and subsequently the
end of this video let me know what you
thought about atomic heart in the
comments down below while you're down
there if you have any questions about
the game that are still puzzling you
feel free to ask furthermore it's
possible I may have made a mistake
throughout this video if so let me know
and I'll make a pin comment explaining
the changes as I stated before we do
lots of Story videos here on the channel
from informative videos like this to
story critiques as well if any of that
sounds interesting to you then feel free
to stick around I recommend not only
playing BioShock if you've enjoyed
atomic heart as they feel quite similar
but also recommend watching the video I
made on the trilogy if you're curious
about its story with that out of the way
though like the video if you enjoy and
subscribe if you're new thinking about
returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye